okay bug spray check water purifier  check band-aids i feel like i'm  forgetting something oh cool  i'll be in charge of this ah that's not  for you no hey dad look at this did you  know the amazon has snakes that can  swallow you  oh that's sick all right we ready to go  harlow we're leaving  warning approaching intersections  get me off the grid calculating route to  secure location  guess what  what  i like spiders i saw that  you got a sticker you're not afraid  anymore  you don't ever have to be scared  is that why you wanted to come back show  me you weren't afraid it's important  what  do you think she had that made  she didn't have that when you have a  body like that everything fits you  perfectly i mean she's like the perfect  ten lemon tarts  double d obviously you know what at some  point you say i play tennis right but if  i play against ron mcenroe then i expect  to lose you know what right i am mcenroe  what are you doing  bye